so um I'm here to talk about conformal
inference and how to do that in tidy
models conformal inference you put those
two words together and if you would ask
me maybe like a year ago what they mean
as stat should be like I don't know so
you know um it's kind of like a an oddly
named technique so in hindsight maybe a
better title for this uh presentation
was how you can make prediction
intervals uh for any type of model
without making very much statistical
assumptions about your data or your
model uh just to remind you if you want
to put in some questions here's the link
for it and also in this wee tiny little
font down here you can see the uh the
link to the slides if you want
them all right so maybe I should start
first by saying well what's a prediction
interval if you've never heard of that
and so a prediction interval it's like a
confidence interval but it's an interval
on a a separate type of of object um if
you had like a 95% predicable that means
that you have a balance where 95% of the
time a new observation that you would
acquire later will fall into that
interval so whereas confidence intervals
are on like the mean prediction this is
about new observations and the little um
diagram here shows you both confidence
interval which is kind of very narrow
for this data set um and a wider
prediction interval and you can see
there's a couple data points on the
bottom and a few on the top that don't
fall in so that's like a I think that's
a 95% interval right there um people use
these uh when they can get them which is
not that often for models um it gives
you a sense of like uncertainty about
your prediction usually so um so it
gives you a sense of like you know how
much should I um like uh not trust the
prediction but you know you can like
sort of calibrate your expectations as
to how good the the prediction
is all right so let's start with just
some data right so this is just like you
know just like a histogram on its side
uh it's 500 data points uh it's centered
around zero you know maybe like plus or
minus like I don't know 0.15 and so you
know you spend some time collecting this
data and then you get the 51st data
point and let's say it falls down here
and it's like well you know it's not
outside the range per se but is that
like a new data point from the same
distribution or is something like
changed like the model drift question
and things like that um and so what we
can do is if we were like from a
statistical standpoint if we want to
make some sort of judgment about whether
this new data point is from our original
distribution well think we could do is
use like good oldfashioned quantiles so
if you wanted to do like um let's say
you wanted a 9% interval what you could
do is get like the uh 05 quantile on the
lower end and the 95% quantile and if
you had um if you were to make like a
completely distribution free
probabilistic statement about that you
could say that you know 90% of the time
when I get data from this distribution
they're going to fall in between that
interval and so like this is where the
conformal part comes in so you would say
that that new data point if it fell
within that interval it conforms to sort
of this original reference distribution
here so if you were to take this data
set compute those particular intervals
so there's a lower 5% and this is like
the 95% inter um quantile then you would
think that any new data point that falls
in here uh would be consistent with the
original data and you can see of course
there's false positives 5% of the time
here and 5% of the time up here and this
particular data point you would not
really consider to be consistent with
the original data so why am I telling
you this like suppose instead of me just
saying we have some data let's say they
were out of sample residuals so let's
say you fit some sort of regression
model you had an extra data set you know
just laying around like we do all the
time and um you took that that model and
you predicted on this different data set
you can compute those residuals and so
that gives you a sense of for the data
that was um collected especially in what
we call this the calibration data set
you could say like on average you know
this is what I expect the the the noise
around my predicted values to be based
on these
residuals so if this is a training set
um and this is a just a nonlinear
function I fit to it um you know we
build the model on this data set we take
that same model fit to the calibration
data set this 500 I just showed you and
calculate the residuals and that
generates this histogram that I I just
showed you and then what we can do is we
can take this you know the zero centered
histogram and basically Center it around
the predicted values of our model so
this is like a test set so we get new
data points we you know the same model
fit here oh and by the way it's I swear
to God it's completely accidental that
these colors match the ones of our
t-shirts I didn't realized until like an
hour ago I was like oof um it's not like
me um so anyway so these are like the
it's a consistently um consistent with
band around the uh predicted values in
here in I guess we're calling that
purple and you can see some of the data
points don't fall inside the band and
some but mostly they do and this is
basically something akin to a prediction
intervals just going about it in a a
completely different way most prediction
intervals are what we call parametric
where you have to make some sort of
statistical or probabilistic assumption
about your data and the model and things
like that um so what we tend to think of
when we do these conformal intervals is
that they have if if it were like a
typical um prediction interal you get
from just straight up linear regression
we'd say that you know a particular data
point has a coverage of let's say 95%
but in this case what we would say is on
a cage across all the samples that we
use the coverage for that interroll is
95% so it's really the the additional
bit here is
average um usually for most uh conformal
Methods at least so if you're a
statistician or some or something like
that and you're interested in the
methodology um there's been quite a lot
written about this especially lately
it's been kind of exploding uh both in
in terms of papers and in terms of
visibility um it has a very strong
frequentist um um theme to it if if you
know what that means we're making we're
basically using quantiles and empirical
distributions and it's sort of when you
read about this it it really sort of
kind of ties in in an indirect way to
what we would call non-parametric
inference so anyway so that's all well
and good um so what's good about it well
they they make very these intervals
require very very minimal assumptions
about your data exchangeable data means
that if I just reorder the data you know
I can get the same results right and and
that's not true for time series but it's
generally true for a lot of other
situations and of course time series are
important so there are specialized
conformal methods that are related time
series um Matt Dano's model time package
has those in them so you can get those
if if that's your thing um it can work
with any type of regression or
classification model so but so far in
the probably package I've only
implemented it for regression so we're
working on that and it's relatively fast
there's a couple of different methods
I'll show you um the ones I'll show you
are all you know relatively fast both
train the the conformal interval U
method and to to make new predictions
there's one called full conformal which
is the one that honestly kind of makes
the most sense to me how this thing
works but it's abominably slow so we
have that in tyy models but like you
probably don't want to do that anyway
the cons is because it doesn't really
make any you know it's making minimal
assumptions and as you'll see in a
little bit um they don't necessarily
extrapolate well so if you're making a
prediction on a new sample and it falls
well outside of your training or
calibration said the coverage of that or
even the interval itself may not be very
good um and so you know that's a little
bit different than what we would see in
things like linear
aggression um let's see what else uh
what so if if that's a problem if you're
not sure you might be saying to yourself
well how am I going to know if I'm
really extrapolating if I have a bunch
of predictors um we do have something
called the applicable package uh was
generated by one of our um interns
Marley a couple years ago and what that
does is it's used to quantify how much
I'm extrapolating from my training set
so you can use applicable to to have a
score that gives you a sense of like how
far out am I or am I sort of like in the
middle of my training
set um and they're probably not great
for small sample sizes for some like
definition of small um you can get
probably intervals but you know it's
hard to say what their coverage would be
okay so um I'm going to show you some
code so I'm going to have a training set
that is a th000 data points a test set
that's 500 and a calibration set which
is where we compute those um residuals
of about the same size of 500
so you can load the tiny models package
down here and we're going to we're going
to be looking at um some results if you
use cross validation like V cross
validation so I generated a cross
validation object here using tiny
models uh the model I'm going to use
which doesn't ordinarily generate um
prediction roles is called a support
Vector machine and here's some code to
uh specify the model and then line seven
here is we just fit that support Vector
Machine model and we can use that to
generate the Curve curve on that or the
the curve on that data point or data set
that I showed you all right so there's
three different conformal methods I'll
go through really quickly the first
one's called split conformal inference
and you've already seen it so it's
basically you take a model you fit it to
your training set you predict your your
calibration set compute the residuals
and go on your Merry way so it's it's
it's pretty simple uh in tiny models you
load that uh with a probably package the
functions we're going to show start with
int conformal so in the the last bit
here is the method so what you do is you
give it your fit in your calibration set
it basically predicts the calibration
set gets residuals and then when you
want to actually get the prediction uh
predictive intervals on new samples you
give it let's say the test set and here
you specify whatever confidence level
you want and then you can see you get
new uh columns here PR lower and PR
upper what does that look like for the
data set that we um just
used is this uh again purple line is our
in this case a board Vector Machine
model uh prediction and then here's our
um prediction intervals you see some of
them down here aren't really overlapping
and so
on so you know as you might imagine it's
pretty fast pretty simple um again the
downside to one of the downsides to it
is the interval widths are always the
same so whether the the variability in
your in your outcome data is really
small or really large at different
points it's always going to be the same
width um you know the downside also to
this is you have to have an extra set of
data laying around that you can use to
estimate that distri distribution um we
don't always have that so one thing you
can do is you can use cross validation
um every time you do cross validation
you have some data you're predicting uh
and those data points were not used by
the corresponding model that generated
the uh um the data used for prediction
is not the same data use to fit the
model inside of cross validation so if
you do 10-fold cross validation you have
10 sets of sort of heldout residuals and
it turns out um there's some math behind
this that says yeah you can with some
slight alterations you can do something
very simple to um split conformal
inference um the theory has only really
been done for for vold cross validation
um so you can use other resampling
methods and tidy models to do this but
you sort of get a warning to saying like
you're at your own risk um I have a link
at near the end of um a GitHub repo
where I've done a ton of simulations and
I did try bootstrapping with this and it
seemed to work pretty well so no
guarantees but it doesn't seem like a
horrible idea to try other resampling
methods so how that works is a little
bit different than what you would
normally do with resampling um in your
control object you have to save the out
of sample predictions that's not very
exotic but the other thing you do is if
you're doing 10f cross validation you
need to save the 10 fitted models that
you generated uh during cross validation
so the easiest way to do that is there's
a argument called extract and just give
it the identity function which just
returns
itself then use the fit resamples
function like you normally would and
then the Inc conformal CV function just
processes all that data and this is the
same thing as it was last time to
generate the
intervals and so again on that same data
set it in this particular case it's not
always like this these intervals are
very very close to the the split
intervals that's not always the case but
um but it's what happened here um also
one one little not about this I found
with very small sample sizes um when
conformal CB plus conformal methods
Center their interval they Center it on
the average prediction of the 10 cross
validated models not the actual model
that you fit on the training set so if
you have a very small sample size those
two things might be different and your
intervals might be kind of shifted in
some places um I might I might try to
fix that if you can fix it but um it's
just like a little
note and then the third and final method
uh which is very different than the
others is called con formalized quanti
regression so quanti regression is a is
a pretty wellknown in statistics
technique where you know when you fit a
line regression and you get a prediction
that's the mean of the outcome
distribution in in a in a uh quantal
regression like a quantal linear
regression what you can do is you can
actually make predictions on whatever
quantal you want so if you want to do
something around the center of the
distribution you would use uh um quantal
regression with a 50% Quanto you know 05
Quant to get the median prediction but
you know it's really if we set it to be
like let's say the 0.05 or the 0.95
quantal that's really what we're trying
to do basically in conformal inference
is we're trying to estimate the
boundaries of of what our predictive
distribution is and so it's really more
direct approach of solving this um this
this this is the same data set I showed
like in that second slide where I had
linear aggression and you can see maybe
it might be hard to see but you can see
these are not equally spaced so the
upside to conformal inference uh using
quanti regression is that you might or
you very well can get um uh intervals
that are not equally spaced like the
other two
methods now linear linear methods here
are maybe not the best of ideas um so
what we do is what something other
people do in the literature is we use a
tree based Ensemble um specifically
Quant random forests and then um that
can give us a prediction R and here's
the same data set you can see for lack
of a better term i' call this like a
chunky sort of line um but it will vary
um across the range if the variance
changes across the rain the other thing
to note here is um you can see when the
data stops this is true of all tree
based methods not just random Forest
that it just sort of goes off to
Infinity with like the same lines and
this is uh especially bad if you start
extrapolating so you can imagine if I
fit a linear aggression to this or
something for this particular data set
like this cloud of points you can
imagine that line just keep increasing
but the uh conformed uh Quantum uh
intervals will just keep going off in
One Direction so you could extrapolate
and get very um you can get intervals
that are so poor that they don't even
contain the predicted value so just with
this particular method especially have
to be uh very sure you're not
extrapolating all right the code's a
little bit different for this one you
need to give it your model fit and you
need to give it both the uh training set
and the calibration set um so it works
best with a split sample and and also
since you're estimating the quantiles
you have to get the confidence level up
front so instead of setting it in the
the predict method you have to do it
here and then we use the Quant uh qrf
function so for quantile regression
Force um so you have to tell it how many
anything you want to pass to that
argument or that function you can do it
here so I'm going to bump up the number
of trees of 2,000 and then they get the
actual intervals you just it's it's a
little bit more simple
simplistic and what's that look like for
our data set again um I don't know it's
kind of interesting uh this seems like
you might be like wow that I don't know
that's kind of scary um but performance
of this is actually pretty good despite
the lack of smoothness of these
intervals um so when you do simulations
and things like this the the idea that
you're getting like step functions
across a range is not that big of a deal
performance
wise speaking of performance um you know
we have to make sure it works so this is
a little bit different than your average
machine learning method because we're
saying if you get intervals from this
function we think they'll have 90 let's
say 90% coverage and so um with this
GitHub uh repo here I did like a bunch
of simulations to make sure these things
actually work the way they're supposed
to work now for the data sets I showed
you like this one um the coverages were
very close to 90% so for the original
split uh conformal plot it was you know
just about CB plus was 80% and then
we're very close to 90% for those
individual data sets and and I have like
a a read me at the at that repo um
generally speaking you know I tried it
with like trees and L regression and
neural Nets and things like that the the
sample size Matters a lot so your
coverage may not be spectacular um if
you have a very small sample size but I
was I was pretty happy with the the
average coverage of those methods so
they seem to be working and doing what
they're supposed to
do uh so what's next uh as I mentioned
we've already imp imped regression
models so probably sometime in the New
Year I'll start looking at doing the
same thing for classification models in
classification in this particular um
domain they they typically are focusing
on situations where we have like a lot
of classes so let's say you're doing
like some some sort of image
classification and there's like 30
things you might classify an image as
what they focus on with conformal
inference is saying like clustering them
saying like well you know what is it
like dog and not dog or hot dog that
whole thing you know if you have a
prediction and you have two class
probabilities are pretty close one thing
conformal inference does for you is to
so tell you whether they're like sort of
equivocal probabilities or not and again
it's a fastly growing field so if
there's a new method methodology that
pops up we will definitely take a look
at it um thanks to Toney mes and Teddy B
groups for listening to me proud about
this and uh test my uh my presentation
and and Joe Rickard did a lot of uh
reading and help uh with me on this to
uh to get a sense of how these things
actually work um speaking of which if
you want to learn learn more there's an
article on Tiny mods.org um the two
references I would really suggest the
most here is uh Christopher mullar um
made this book uh it says conformal
inference with python but this is
probably the best reference if you want
to get like a like a Layman sense of
like how these things are working so
it's an excellent book you can get it
off Amazon if you're more of the
statistical kind of person uh Ryan
timani has a really nice set of notes on
the the various methods and how they
work and then this awesome conformal
prediction rep when GitHub has like any
reference that comes up ever um they'll
pretty much list it in probably this
talk or whatever there so um yeah anyway
that's it
thanks thank you we have a few questions
coming in do these prediction intervals
break down in the presence of
heteroscedasticity
heteroscedasticity I can't spell it I
won't even try um yeah the first two
well they don't break down they're just
on average they're right so if you go to
the um do I have Wi-Fi if you go to the
article on T mods.org
um you know we did a little
simulation um where we took something
that had uh different variants as you go
and so if you do like the split
intervals you know they're they're bad
here they're bad here they overdo it
here so on average they're fine right so
in other words they don't they don't
it's like you can't compute them they're
just not especially great and just in
case you were wondering you would
probably use the conformal inference
there and they sort of align pretty well
so you can see the the the quanti method
here is very tight in that area and
widens out where it's supposed to so
that's what I would suggest if you think
that's the case uh
yeah can these be used for anomaly
detection in deployed models and then
drive some sort of emergency action to
avoid anomalous predictions yeah that's
a that's a good question so um I've seen
people on social media say that uh I
don't know that I would buy into it so
much if you were using this you could
look at the width of the interval to get
a sense of how it's going um within
within the mainstream of your training
data so as long as you stay within your
training data um you're fine and
actually um it wouldn't be very good at
all for anomaly detection for something
that's an aberration because it's
extrapolation because look what happens
as you go a little bit further right
it's like Boop these goes off into
infinity and actually my fitted curve
goes out here so you know this is the
one you would probably use if you want
to judge the uncertainty by the
confidence inter width because the other
two methods have a a fixed width um and
it only would really detect anomalies
that are sort of where your data already
live so that's my answer of that
question we'll do one more um when
evaluating performance of prediction
intervals for example coverage is that
something you pit your living in
probably or some kind of uh new package
like yard stick oh well like the
evaluation of whether these things work
or not no I'll just stuff that in a
GitHub repo because it's like a million
files of simulations and things like
that but if if the question is like if
you're going to develop methods for uh
interval estimates like like this um
yeah probably is the best place for them
um we've added a bunch of Edgar actually
um did a lot of work and added a bunch
of calibration tools for um for models
and we put this in probably probably you
know it tends to focus on things you
would do after the model and that seems
like um the kind of thing that would fit
there so yeah I'd most likely put them
there